welcome back everybody I have one more
story to share from the world of social
media this is what I'm liking
[Music]
[Applause]
each month it's a time for celebrating
the rich culture and history of millions
of Americans a woman in Rhode Island
does it in her own tiny way literally
she makes jewelry of miniature
Vietnamese food and says it's her way of
connecting with her Vietnamese heritage
so we have some of her jewelry in studio
it's so cool there are dumplings spring
rolls Bond me even a bowl of pho it's
incredible let's get this very talented
woman in here everybody watching on NBC
10 wjar say hi to Hana what's up Hannah
hello your jewelry is so beautiful and
very detailed so how how hard is that to
make well it's definitely a process
um something like the spring rolls they
have a transparent rice paper wrapping
so I have to use translucent clay to
make them something like the pho has a
broth so I have to use um dyed resin to
make that and so it's a lot of trial and
error luckily I grew up eating
Vietnamese food my dad is an amazing
cook and even though I can't quite cook
like him I'm making Miniatures that look
just about the same
well this Joy is also meaningful to you
so can you tell us about that course so
I grew up Vietnamese in an all-white
town and as a non-vietnamese speaker the
best way for me to connect with my
heretic was actually through food and so
what I love about making these videos
and sharing the process is that
Vietnamese kids will come into my
comments and say my grandfather makes
that that's my uncle's favorite dish and
having that little moment of connection
with them is really special that's super
special thank you so much Hannah I love
it it's so cool and fresh and
interesting the idea I'm liking your
post right now right
that's not all though our season long
partner pilot pin makers in friction the
go-to race will pin of the Kelly
Clarkson show want to celebrate those
celebrating their Heritage just like you
ma'am so they're going to be writing
your check for a thousand dollars how
does that sound
wow that sounds amazing thank you for
joining us
and thank you to all our guests today
Priyanka Chopra Jonas Max and Bash
markovsky Emily crotch Amy and Dana
you'll have a Great Dane and it's not
try and change it
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
guys I'm going